[Music]
you
this is 13 year old Najib Ali undergoing
long tests at a hospital in Athens
oh god book personally and highly
deerhorn explaining her son's injuries
his mother fattens says it's taken a
year to see specialist consultants the
first since they arrived in Greece
generally my son feels like someone is
strangling him the family's home near
the Syrian city of Homs was hit by a
bomb Nagi was so badly injured he was
left unable to walk did you avoid estaba
cart effective harakiri ani
I know Talal hired get a nonfat egg and
tuefel gambit de Rossi will our Allen
Madras a tonic tea rehabilitate her
brother Carter forbid life happy food
battle is available large if a big
holiday her before Najib is already in a
wheelchair but doctors have discovered
new problems he is told he needs an
urgent even life-saving operation the
teenager has the kidneys of an old man
and is facing the prospect of renal
failure he's got a serious neurological
problem that needs to be dealt with
pretty soon in order not to jeopardize
his kidney function and not having him
and topping entire Alice's something
that will be very debilitating
the charity goodwill caravan is also
supporting Ibrahim Jabara and his wife
who have six children two of them they
say are unrecognizable since a chemical
attack in Raqqa in Syria but they are
not the only young victims of the Syrian
war now in Greece needing medical help
there are no official figures but
charities working here estimate there
are several thousand high-risk migrant
children requiring specialist paediatric
intervention Omar
rolls around the floor like a toddler he
is eight years old but has no speech
delay I can my bad that wasn't bad
advice trailer want to are of Turkey
initial inception keep had to Annie had
the mosquito had known to study Bill
Mariana Anaheim and I Nieman Muscat Minh
Oklahoma any banana actor Shimon German
who will be unhurt this way Masseria
Bill Monroe they were sheltering in a
school with around 60 or 70 other
families we can't independently verify
their claim but the parents say Syrian
doctors told them their tween the sons
Omar and Mohammed are the victims of
sarin gas
yeah near Metairie hair unicum zoo I was
she Oh
Yanni we had didn't carry any on one
murder an additional I admonish and
agree her we have Hollister
and it'll be secured and dead Rehim Oh
any addition media in Chambord and of
the [ __ ] the White House in her yet the
ana matically need a kebab might become
an issue and others about
Najeeb still has shrapnel in his spine
the neck strain old x-ray back from his
hospitalization that shows the skeletal
injuries and also the lung injuries that
the boy had he's been a paraplegic for
four years
his family pushed him in a wheelchair
across Syria then paid people smugglers
to take them in a dinghy to Europe in
the hope they would find a doctor to
help him walk again Maddon enough at me
as a some sort of the hated me mad him
she resorted Ekrem hockey Rita Bonnie
the Quran on disability and because
they'd be anemic of you and a MOOC
around the island she as we speak to
Najib's parents in the corridor outside
Omar has arrived with his father
[Music]
they are similarly beholden to anyone
prepared to pay for or give them free
healthcare but today is not their day
when they're told nobody can see them
and to go home again for most migrants
arriving in Europe isn't as simple as
just starting a new life they bring with
them the injuries and trauma of years of
war and most are ill-equipped to deal
with it hundreds of thousands of
migrants have passed through Greece but
tens of thousands are now trapped
because Gateway borders to the rest of
Europe are closed after a hard winter
the days are getting warmer which for
most people makes survival easier but
not everyone we sit in the shade to meet
an 11-year old boy who can't face direct
sunlight Manan is pictured with his
sister Natalija a few years ago this is
him now he suffered third-degree burns
to much of his body and needs plastic
surgery after fleeing conflict in Syria
fire broke out in his family's tent in
the migrant camp in Greece so his burns
everywhere apart from his legs and his
chest
was what was he wearing on his clothes
he had clothes they took the clothes off
cousin parent volunteers salaam al deen
has been helping the family and shows us
a video of the night of the fire
[Music]
you can hear the screams of man Ann's
mother she had to choose which of her
children to try to rescue from the
flames
first she saved not Lea sparing at least
one child more serious injury nobody got
inside to save the baby
the mother jumped inside them but the
baby no man got inside there to get the
baby she took her son
so the Yakama be our third
I went in had
damn pictures
volunteers salam has witnessed the
arrival of thousands of migrants more
than a third of those who've come to
Greece are children
charities say Greece can't cope with the
numbers needing medical help and want
other countries to share the burden the
Greek people have been wonderful but
because there is such an exodus of
refugees coming to Greece the medical
services are overstretched Sunnah G
another day at a different Hospital to
see a neurologist about his spine do you
feel any here how's the ocean
so this is a sort of involuntary
movement it's called clones Ramos built
and it is a sign that he says Palin coal
has been severed and this is an
automatic movement really he doesn't
have any any conscious movement of his
legs girl Hana kotti muchas de colina or
the other he had a grizzly and Haruka
Hedy allow the lighted hair guru the
family faced a rollercoaster of emotions
to try to improve and save Najib's life
I'm going to start calling now and not
find a way through there's really when
the doctor says he'll try to put them in
touch with a kidney expert but despair
over the long-term prognosis do you
think that there's any chance he could
walk again I think this is this very
simple and whisper work bursa canyon
logical causal a colossal mother hole
she as Neji battles injuries from four
years ago in the last few weeks the
family's home town has been hit again in
a fresh strike Najib's grandparents
lived in the house next door
mom I'm sure
double
is a fiddle Coolio man I'm sorry again
reliant on the goodwill of strangers
Najib's father is helped by a passerby
to get his son down the hospital steps
it's now over a year since the family
arrived in Greece and they still don't
know when or if Najib will get the
treatment he needs